random walks provide probabilistic
models for a bunch of settings in fact
we've seen a couple already so let's
examine what they are in general so the
setup for a random walk is that you have
a digraph and we can also also often
think and talk about the digraph as
those a state mistake diagram for a
machine with States so here's a three
state digraph blue orange and green and
the part that becomes probabilistic is
that we think of the process of which
edge to follow when you're at a given
state is made probabilistically and the
only rules are that we're going to
assign probabilities to the edges in a
way like this where for example what I'm
telling you is there's a 1/3 probability
that I'll follow the edge from o to O
and a 2/3 probability that I'll follow
from the the edge from o to green and
the rule is simply that the sum of the
probabilities on the outgoing edges has
to sum to 1 so let's fill in the rest of
the graph in a legal way so here we have
B with 1/2 probability of going from B
to B 1/4 from B to O and 1/4 from B to G
and the Green State is certain in one
step if you're at Green to go to blue
next that there's only one edge out it
has probability 1
now gamblers ruin it can be seen as an
example of this kind of a random luck
the states were the amount of money that
you had ranging from zero when you're
bankrupt to t when you've reached your
target and n is the start state which is
your initial stake the green areas are
weighted with a probability of P of
winning a bet so we have transitions
from k to k plus 1 for K less than T of
probably the weight probability P and
likewise the red edges are weighted with
the probability of losing a bet Q or 1
minus P so there is a digraph or a state
machine that describes the gamblers
ruined problem as a probabilistic walk
on a graph and the typical kind of
question that we would ask about a
random walk on a graph would be what's
the probability of reaching
hey the target before reaching zero
bankrupt given that you're starting at
some state estate and so any books come
up in a bunch of quite different
settings for example in physics Brownian
motion is the random motion of a
particle that's being buffeted by atomic
forces and it's modeled by saying that
this particle can move in any direction
in three space and chosen in uniformly
at random and the theory of Brownian
motion it had been observed first
without being understood Einstein was
the first one to come up with a random
walk model and corresponding theorems
about the behavior of particles under
Brownian motion in fact that was one of
the main components of his Nobel Prize
he wasn't given a Nobel Prize for
relativity at the time because it had
not yet been firmly proven although it
was widely celebrated another case is in
finance we've already seen how gamblers
ruin reflects or seems to reflect the
biased random oscillation of price of
stock prices over time and we will see
at the end of this set of videos an
application of random walks on a graph
to model web search and clustering of a
focus on vertices in a digraph so the
general kinds of questions that come up
when you're talking about random walks
on graphs are illustrated by this simple
three state example with blue orange and
green we might ask for example starting
at state B what's the probability of
reaching state all in seven steps and
that would be easy enough to calculate
in this small example but it would be a
typical question a more interesting
general question would be what's the
average number of steps that it takes to
get from B to all I mean you could with
one problem with probability 1/4 you go
there in one step but with probability
1/8 you go there in three steps and so
on you can
again explicitly and easily enough what
the average number of steps would be to
always in this simple example and will
shortly remark about general ways to
solve that problem and finally you can
ask a gamblers ruin type question what's
the probability of starting at B of
getting to G before oh well in this
trivial example you can just read off
the answer you are gonna get to G before
oh with 50/50 probability because from B
you have to go one place or the other
with equal probability but in general
this becomes a more interesting and
complicated question which you can solve
by methods that we're about to lay out
let me just remind you that we've
already seen an interesting and
illustrative example of random walk on a
graph when we were looking at Toyne
course at coin tosses the problem for
example of if I toss a fair coin and I
wait for three consecutive tosses that
form the pattern h th or the pattern t
th and i want to know what's the
probability of winning because H th
comes before t th I can model that with
a we said as with an infinite tree
diagram using our tree method for
forming probability spaces but the tree
was very recursively defined sub trees
were isomorphic to the original tree
which allowed us in fact to come up with
a finite description of the infinite
tree that amounted to a finite state
machine or a finite graph so let's look
at that example in more detail if I'm
trying to model the coin flipping thing
like we start off in a state where the
previous two flips don't exist I haven't
flipped anything yet the state's going
to record the values of the previous two
flips and with no prior flips there's a
50-50 chance that the first flip will be
H in which case I'm in the state with
just an H and nothing proceeding or
there's a 50/50 chance I flip a T in
which case I'm in the state in which
there's been a T and nothing previous
but I can already say something then
about the probability of tossing h th
before t th namely the probability of
winning probability of winning is of
course the probability of winning given
that I start at the start state with no
prior flips but the probability that I
win starting here is simply the
probability that I win at starting at
the state noting age and/or the
probability that I win at the state
started nothing T with the two
probabilities weighted equally since
this is a fair coin and there's a 50/50
chance of going each way that is the
probability of winning given no prior
tosses is half the probability of
winning if the first toss is an H plus
half the probability of winning if the
first plus is a T this is just an
application of the law of total
probability so I'm continuing in this
way let's expand more of the diagram so
suppose that I have tossed a head and
then after that I toss a head and I go
to state h h or i toss it t and i go to
state h T so here I'm just recording the
previous two flips with the most recent
one on the right okay this this
structure of the state diagram tells us
that if I want to know what the
probability of winning given that I
flipped exactly one head at the start
the probability is simply by again total
probability the probability of winning
from HH weighted by 1/2 and the
probability of winning from HK weighted
by 1/2 and I wind up again with a simple
linear equation that connects the
probability of winning in one state with
the probability of winning in the states
that it goes to let's continue and do
another example so it's like wise if I
expand what happens after I flip a tea
or an H after having flipped the first
head I get a corresponding equation that
the probability of winning after a
single tail is the same as the problem
half the probability of winning with a
tail followed by an H or a tail followed
by a tail this is a more interesting
part of the diagram we're supposed that
my past two flips have been two H's well
if I flip an H again then I'm back in
state where the previous two flips were
ages or if I flip at a that I'm in this
state a
hey where the previous flips were an H
and T in that order and that tells me if
I want to know about the probability of
winning even HH now it's the probability
of winning given HH plus the probability
of winning given HT and again it's a
linear equation connecting up the
probability of winning in one state with
the probability of winning in other
states possibly itself but there's no
circularity here it's just a system of
linear equations well there's what the
whole diagram looks like in particular
once you've flipped HT if you then flip
an H you've won because you got two H th
first and you stay in the wins state
forever or alternatively once you flip
TT if you flip an H you've lost because
TT has come up first
if you flip the T again you stay in
state TP and what we can say is the
probability of winning if you're in the
win state is 1 and the probability of
winning if you're in the lose state is 0
and overall I simply have this system of
linear equations for the probability of
winning in one state given other states
and I can solve these linear equations
to find the probability of winning in
the start state which is simply the
probability of winning so looking back
at our questions for random walks where
we asked whether the probability of
reaching oh and seven steps starting at
B what's the probability of that what's
the average number of steps to go from B
to oh what's the probability of reaching
G before Oh starting it B in every case
these questions can be formulated simply
as solving systems of linear equations
whose structure directly reflects the
structure of the digraph